High School Musical the musical the
series behind-the-scenes let's hit it
[Applause]
we are shooting episode 8 which is the
tech rehearsal episode in a normal
theater run this would be when you put
together all the technical elements
lights sounds costumes in Episode seven
the theater these Tyburn down so now we
are in this brand-new space miss Jen is
trying to pull it together this is where
the High School Musical movie premiered
her one line her one moment didn't
happen the biggest thing about this
episode is that we've got the original
Ryan Lucas Grabeel stepping back into
literally the Ryan hat which he brought
from his home back in LA and he's back
on set we're all so excited
working with Lucas Grabeel was a dream
he's saying live every single take I
don't know how he does it he just like
opens his mouth and like this beautiful
voice flows out it was so cool to kind
of have him there to help pass the baton
and get his support for the show when we
were reading the table read everybody's
like oh we already knew Lucas was gonna
be here I was like Luba
Ryan is gonna be on set what it is crazy
to be back here but I have to say the
moment I stepped on the set I felt the
energy these kids are incredible I'm
kind of coming in kind of late in the
game right before they actually put up
this musical to help miss Jen have the
confidence and the drive to get these
kids ready to put on a great show
we're making history
paster
[Music]
mischance say something ouch
[Music]